he's also known for getting schooled in
congressional hearings like this one in
which candice owens
owns him after he tried to accuse her of
advocating on behalf of adolf hitler
let me play for you the first 30 seconds
of a statement she made
about adolf hitler he is assuming that
black people will not go pursue the full
two-hour clip
and he purposefully extracted he cut off
and you didn't hear the question that
was asked of me
he's trying to present as if i was
launching a defense of hitler in germany
when in fact the question that was asked
of me
was returning to whether or not i
believed that hitler was a
whether or not i believed in nationalism
and that nationalism was bad and what i
responded to was that i do not believe
that we should be characterizing hitler
as a nationalist
he was a homicidal psychopathic maniac
that killed his own people
a nationalist would not kill their own
people that is exactly what i was
referring to in the clip and he
purposely wanted to give you a cut up
similar to what they do to donald trump
to create a different narrative and
there it was you saw the look on lou's
face there imagine being a u.s
congressman
with degrees from stanford in georgetown
and getting schooled
by candace owens in the halls of
congress now as it relates to harvard
lou who was born in taiwan likes to say
the federal government is
biased against asian americans but watch
how he shouts
at a member of the u.s civil rights
commission for calling out harvard's
anti-asian discrimination
in its admissions policy in fact just
yesterday or david foyster filed a brief
in the streets for fear of trade
admissions
against harvard case in the supreme
court he did not bring in irrelevant
issues there are more asian americans at
these ivy leagues
these are different issues happening uh
in other words how dare you bring up
actual discrimination and systemic
racism it doesn't fit our narrative
after all welcome in the host of the
reuben report dave rubin
author of don't burn this book thinking
for yourself in an
age of unreason dave this is the point
of show where i hand it over to you
and let you speak john you gave me a lot
in that intro i was making notes and i
got a lot of things to say about all
this well first off let's just be clear
about one thing which
is that if there is one privilege in
america we're told a lot about privilege
these days if there is one privilege
it is democrat privilege and that is
what
jeffrey toobin is getting here that alan
dershowitz or rudy giuliani or a litany
of other
people are never afforded including you
and i and any of your audience watching
this would never be afforded
democrat privilege right so you're
allowed to masturbate on a zoom call or
pay a woman to have an abortion or the
series of other
things that you're allowed to do where
the media will either ignore what you've
done or deflect or blatantly lie
whatever it might be as for ted liu
you know i actually did a college event
that very same day with candice
she left that hearing and then i met her
at a school and
i am so proud of candace for for doing
what she did there because ted lou
is the perfect example of what you laid
out in the intro which is
this sort of really nothing person
who's like a creation of the media and
the democratic establishment so he
thinks he can play
an obviously selectively edited clip
candace owens in no way supports hitler
her point as she laid out clearly was
about nationalism and that you can be a
nationalist
meaning believe in borders for your
country and a cultural identity for your
people
and you wouldn't kill your own people
okay so she and clearly she made her
feelings about hitler
clear but ted lou wants to play a
selectively edited clip and he knows
what will happen by doing it his goal
was i will play something selectively
edited and then
the media will run with that making it
seem like candace owens
is supporting hitler and of course
candace is too good for that game so it
didn't happen and then one other thing
on lou
which is that moment that you talked
about there i mean here is an asian man
basically defending actual systemic
racism
at harvard against asian people he's
he's an embarrassment
as a public official and as a person
i've gotten into it in full uh
transparency
we've gotten into it a little bit on
twitter i think he's called me racist
once or twice maybe once or twice i mean
that's the thing though
i didn't intend to make this so much
about ted lou but you know you uncover
those clips and you just have to point
it out and candace owens
in that moment my favorite part about
that clip is ted liu being like oh god i
jus i stepped in it
here now i had to sit and listen to
the yeah that was embarrassing for ted
luke all right let's also talk dave
about the
biden vaccine push i had the opportunity
to come visit you out in la i would
imagine though
the federal government will not be
getting the same kind of hospitality you
showed me if they come knocking on your
door just a guess
get unlimited sushi for everybody and
all the tequila you could drink no
government operatives will not be
getting that at my house i mean this
idea
that we went from two weeks to flatten
the curve to a year and a half later
we are sending government operatives to
your house to find out if you're
vaccinated i mean
this is dystopian stuff we are in a
dystopian future right now
in 2021 america it's nobody's business
but yours and say your spouse or your
family members
and perhaps your doctor whether you've
been vaccinated or not everyone as we've
all said from the beginning of this or
at least every
uh sane person has said you have every
right to take whatever
responsibilities you want and wear a
mask and follow whatever
you know if i don't expect somebody to
not follow an order at a store right so
if a store says you got to wear a mess
then you should wear a mask
in that store but everyone has a right
to do what they think is right with
their body what happened to these people
you know my body my choice they don't
they don't seem to be for my body my
choice anymore now they're for
your body our choice so look
no john they can't have my sushi and my
tequila there you go it was also
interesting too i don't know if you saw
this but
a lot of the left tried to push this
back on candace owens because she said
the same thing
about medical choice and she just shut
them down right away and she said no i
believe in medical choice i don't
believe in killing
innocent babies which you know they were
trying to make this about abortion in my
body and my choice etc
the other thing too i want to talk about
is dr fauci as it relates to this he's
getting
you know his dander up a little bit uh
getting some confidence i don't know why
but here he is
it's easy to get it's free and it's
readily available so
you know you've got to ask what is the
problem
get over it get over this political
statement just get over it
and try and save the lives of yourself
and your family
i mean that it should be easy right dave
we all should just get over it i mean
the fact that they've been on both sides
of basically every major issue when it
comes to the pandemic mass no mass
social you know whatever
but you know dr fauci says we should
just get over it so
i mean i guess we're going to right well
john let me say this i actually
don't think that's overconfidence by him
or somehow like a new robust confidence
that shows complete desperation what
he's realizing is
that despite everything that they've
done a certain amount of people have
some
healthy skepticism about this whole
thing which you know three years ago if
you had some skepticism about the
government
uh that would be a thing that the left
would care about right like you
shouldn't
trust these crazy warmongering
capitalists or something like that
um but now we're get over it i mean his
his demeanor as if you should never
question anything that the government
tells you uh you have every
right to do that you have a duty to do
that i mean it's actually i say this to
you all the time john but this is the
thing
that separates us from the animals we
have the ability to think and use logic
and reason now i'm not saying don't get
vaccinated if you want to get vaccinated
but for him to basically be like get
over it you know you have to just
do it because we say it and also there's
a
further point in that clip where his
implication is that you're still going
to be killing people if you don't get
vaccinated this
this disease this virus which we know 97
basically to
99.5 recovery rate for people who aren't
vaccinated they tried to scare the hell
out of everybody you know two weeks ago
with delta variant that didn't quite do
it
now they're they're working on a new one
it's like you know what a healthy
skepticism
of the government or of any system of
power i
i thought that was something that that a
free person would want to believe in
but he's using he's using guilt
basically you're going to kill grandma
as if it didn't happen enough in the
last year and a half yeah i was i was
thinking they were just going to go
ahead and skip ahead to the omega
variant because it just sounds more
ominous and uh you know that's really
what they're going for here
dave great to see you as always you know
an important thing too about your book
you know
when it relates to dr fatch i just want
to make this point real quick is
thinking for yourself
doesn't mean oh i'm going to put my
medical expertise up against dr fauci i
mean of course
going to your doctor and having this
conversation doctor the federal
government tells me i should get the
vaccine
what do you think i should do doc
because you know my medical history and
records a lot better and that's
the kind of stuff that we try to apply
here uh but you know
if we god forbid we don't uh comply with
saint fauci
right john be informed don't be a
mindless drone and
and you're welcome for tequila anytime
all right dave i only had
one shot just to be clear and i took an
uber that was
everything was everything was perfectly
above board dave great to see you thanks
so much
good to see you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell